welcome to have been pawned and how to
serve billions of requests and terabytes
of data without going broke
I'm going to start this off by telling
you a little bit about myself
my name is Stefan I'm Icelandic and for
this whole reason of being Icelandic you
probably have a measurable portion of
the entire country here in the room with
you
I'm a principal software engineer at
Lucidity in Reykjavik also Microsoft MVP
and I haven't been pound contributor and
maintainer and have been for for a while
that's a link to my blog
if you want to take a look at it
but to start this off uh have been
pawned
to answer all your questions then yes
you have
it was launched on December 4th 2013 by
Troy hunt Troy Huntsman Australian he
used to frequent NDC but unfortunately
he's not here with us today
and allows like the gestivities that
allow users to check out if their data
have or has been leaked in a Dairy
Bridge
some statistics
currently it contains breaches for 600
674 websites
over 12 billion email addresses which
don't have to think about very long to
realize that that's more email addresses
than our humans in the world
and over 850 million passwords or their
hashes to be more correct
Alabama has a notification service
where you can register and verify your
email and how I've been Poland will let
you know if that email is found in data
breaches as they come in
it also has a domain search
functionality for example if you have
your own domain or if you're a system
administrator you can verify your domain
with haven't been pawned and it will
then let you know if any email address
is under that domain are found in a data
breach
since this is very handy
then
it also has an ingestion pipeline which
is used by law enforcement and
government so for example agencies like
the FBI and the NCAA NCAA for those that
don't knows pretty much the equivalent
of the FBI in the UK
they actually feed data or passwords
into have been phoned through an API
pipeline that we have
and just over the last year they
ingested millions of passwords
so it's good to get these things these
are these are passwords that they find
for example in their investigations
uh certain teams from different
governments also have
access to have been pawned they get they
get free access to it so they can like
if any every any government email
addresses are found in data breaches
these certain teams are notified
and as far as I know and the last time I
checked the little 34 governments signed
up it's USA UK Germany Iceland I think
pretty much all in other countries for
example
uh
but
gonna ask you very quickly if you
recognize this number I'm not I'm not
expecting you to you probably don't and
you're not supposed to
but be clear a little bit later on
but many of you might recognize this
number for the sole reason not like we
all know how to count
but
this number is actually uh according to
data breaches the most popular password
in the world
so I'm really really hoping that none of
you actually have this as a password
somewhere if you do please go ahead and
change it
but if you worked with well computers
you would probably recognize that this
is a hexadecimal stream
but to be more correct this is actually
Xiao one hash of one two three four five
six
and why is that important
because we can actually use the show and
Ash to see if one two three four five
six has been on data breach
simply take the five first five
characters go to this URL get a text
file back and then look for the rest of
the hash in the file
and there you see the number behind
this is how often one two three four
five six has been seen in a data Bridge
yes that's
37.6 million times
and it's probably been in a database a
lot more often these are just the
databases that we can actually see that
the password has been in there
so
I have been pawned as an API the pawn
passwords API and that's sort of becomes
the focus of this talk because that's
where most of the traffic goes
like I said in there there are 850
million password hashes in that API
All the known breach passwords that we
have found in the data breaches we both
have sha1 and ntlm hashes uh nt11 hashes
are
good because like I said or like it says
you can download the hashes for offline
use like in a big file
so you can you can check offline you
don't have to have to use the API for
everything
and for example in the case of ntlm if
you're if you're a system administrator
for an active directory domain you can
actually fetch that file and see if any
of your users
have well what's considered uh unfit
passwords for use without knowing what
the password is
it can be integrated in a number of ways
and it has been so just just to name
three cases one password users haven't
been pawned for its Watchtower feature
they have a feature
where they actually like go over your
passwords that you have in your password
manager and can actually tell you no
this one is not too complex and this one
is actually vulnerable
Mozilla users have been pawned for
Firefox monitor so they can tell you if
the email address you're signing up for
has uh or using in any Vlog and it has
been in a data Bridge and even online
where I used to work uh
actually can tell users when they're
logging in
if their password is not safe anymore
so these are just uh just a few examples
for example the online one this is what
happens when you log in with a bad
password you get notified
it says Hey of course
you know the only place where they
actually have your password when you're
logging in so they say hey like this
password you're using is not safe you
should go to account management and
change it and enable two-factor
authentication if you haven't
and then it like gives you links to like
good password hygienes uh
in the middle you see the one password
integration it has what star in the big
Red Square there is actually checking
they have a pin code API to see if the
passwords are any of your passwords in
your one password Vault are insecure
and Firefox monitor tells you that like
your email address has been exposed in
several data breaches yes that's my
email address
I'm actually happy that it's just 11. it
probably could be a lot more
um and then it tells you like which data
pieces you've been in and what data was
actually leaked in that data breach
so
you can easily look up and see if a
password is unfit for use
just consider
any password that's in there to be unfit
for use and why is that because
these password lists were pretty much
since we have the passwords that means
the bad guys have the passwords as well
and they regularly go through this list
and just like go rampant on services
with botnets like checking every or
usually the most popular passwords and
basically see what what sticks and
unfortunately a lot of them stick
now
the password itself is never sent to the
Amazon API and neither is the full hash
of it and that's because of K anonymity
and I'm going to explain that in a
little bit
but that's used to prevent uh for
example if your network traffic was
going through a proxy whoever controls
the proxy can't actually see what
passwords you're looking up because that
would be bad
so pretty easy to use calculate the
shell one hash of the password
issue a request look up the rest of it
in the text file and see if you can find
the rest of the hash in there
but to make the example like even more
clear
let's start with Hunter two this is a
this is a story from IRC I remember how
many of you remember IRC
[Music]
see if you can spot the joke in there
so basically this is a chat going on
between two people one of them saying
hey if you type in your password it just
shows up the Stars so the guy types in
his password hunter2 doesn't look like
stars to me so the other guy pays it
back saying no it looks like stars to me
oh so he can go hunter too my Hunter
doing Hunter too
right
doesn't look funny to you and that guy
said yeah I just see a bunch of stars
well she's like when you type Hunter too
it shows up with stars wait do you know
my password uh no because like I copy
pasted your stars so it like shows
correctly up with you
oh okay
so let's use Hunter 2 as an example this
is the Xiao one hash 402 and what we're
interested in is
these parts
the green part is actually what we will
be appending to the URL
so we do a get request to the API the
green part
we get back a text file and we will be
looking for a line starting with red
part
and in the case of one to two
this is what you'll find and yes someone
or some people have used Hunter 2 23 000
times as a password
probably because they thought it was a
good idea it isn't
um
so that's that's how easy it is to
actually use the API
the two sort of go over the hosting
environment
uh hosting environment is that simple
really the hashes are just text files
they're stored in Azure blob storage
email addresses are stored in Azure
table storage for we actually use the
domain as a partitioning key and the uh
everything before that sign is a row key
both the email and domain search is run
as Azure functions the hash files are
also served by Azure functions like all
they do is like it's just an HTTP
trigger fetches the text file and
returns it back
and this is actually all these Azure
functions are open sourced at least the
panel passwords one are so you can
actually look them up there if you want
uh
so traffic is growing fast
this is the request per month that the
phone passwords API receives
started out pretty small then it is
gradually increasing and it currently
seems to be almost increasing at an
exponential rate
I hope it doesn't continue doing that
because we're gonna have to figure
something out then
but just to look at the numbers as of
this month
like all of the xiaomon the ntlm hashes
are 60 gigabytes that's all the text
files
now considering like for both ntlm and
channel one you really just have over 1
million text files because there's a
limited key range in there
the average tax value is 30 kilobytes
and we're currently serving over 5
billion HTTP requests per month
so putting that down is
it's over 2000 requests per second every
second every minute every hour every day
all the time on average
so that's a lot
uh when I was actually gathering this
data I figured out like when when did I
actually put in a proposal for this talk
and any proposal I actually said I was
mentioning 1.6 billion requests per
month and that was because the numbers I
had were from March 22 too so I'm sorry
that this was a lie
because currently this is up to five
like I said 5 billion requests as of
this month
and to sort of try to
put this into perspective
of how much data this is
this is
126.8 terabytes per month of data that's
being served
and I was trying to figure out like okay
that's a it's a lot of data
like what can I compare it with to sort
of uh give you an idea how much it
actually is
but the so I was thinking okay like how
big is GitHub and the numbers I found
were actually from two years ago so it's
probably bigger now
but all of the open source repositories
on GitHub three years ago were 20
terabytes
so this is six times that
so it's sort of sort of puts into
perspective of how much data is actually
being transferred
so if you do some maths
serving this like straight out of azure
was nothing in between would be
expensive
if you think about us fetching tax files
from blob storage it would be 5 billion
read operations
uh
I actually had to update that number
should be a 126 terabytes not 1125 but
it's not going to make all the
difference
and putting this into the Azure
calculator comes out to many dollars and
not such wow
to be more exact it would be more than
twelve thousand six hundred dollars per
month just just to serve this data and
it's like we're just reading data and
putting it back and that's because
Azure actually builds you for the amount
of data that you send through the
network and for of course for the read
operations from the blobs
but as like probably all of you figured
out this is completely static data so
there's no reason for us to do this all
the time every time so
of course we cache all the things in
there
but caching is not enough like we could
cache like just in the Azure function
and save on the read operations but we'd
still be serving those terabytes of data
so we had to figure out uh something
else
so the obvious reason would be to put
procedure in front of it and we went
with cloudflare
they have a CDN their CDN is fast it's
actually very very fast Global reach
they have 250 Edge nodes
all over the world
like 10 000 networks connect pretty much
directly to them that's isps
like Cloud providers
and a lot of other people
they have a free tier which does a lot
of the things that I'll be talking about
without you having to pay anything
actually
so this seems like a very perfect fit
and when I say it's faster than the pink
I actually mean that literally because
they say
that 95 of world's population is within
50 milliseconds of a cloud for data
center it takes you 100 milliseconds to
Blink
just to put that into perspective
so
Cloud free caching uh
cloudflare is very simple you basically
just run out your domain through them
and they they do a lot of things just
out of the box and a lot of things is
just pretty much just like flipping on
switches there are some things you have
to think of well it depends on the
content type you're serving it's going
to be easy or not
but we figured okay we could just set
the cache TTL or the time to live to a
very high value and that is currently
set to 30 days
so we're basically telling all the cloud
for Edge nodes to Cache The Blob files
for 30 days on the edge nodes
but you get a lot of other perks as well
from cloudflare like they they give you
https they can give you HTTP 213 like
all the latest protocols product
compression they just do all of these
things for you and you don't have to
worry about
like flipping those switches on your own
web servers
the initial implementation that we
actually did was
pretty much just create a cloudflare
worker that's
it's pretty much just a snippet of of
JavaScript that you can run on the cloud
for Edge nodes
so what that does is it gets a request
goes to the origin which is the Azure
servers
fetches the data sets some course
headers so people can like do this
directly from their browsers
validates the request like is it a get
request is the like hash prefix valid
it's five characters Etc
and then we do URL normalization because
one of the things that is sneaky is that
the URLs are case sensitive well
technically not all of it because the
scheme HTTP or https isn't and the host
name is not
but the rest of the URL is case
sensitive
so to
for example if we would fetch
if we would fetch the hash file for ffff
all in lower case web servers would look
at it differently as in if it was all
uppercase so what the cloudflare worker
does is basically just
just the URL converts the range to
uppercase so we're always fetching the
same thing otherwise would be could be
taking up multiple cash slots for the
same request
the cloudflare worker is open source as
well if you want to take a look at it
so that's that's there
the initial results of that
implementation was that the cache it was
99.5 percent
which is a lot
so with our current numbers like that
would bring the bill down from 12 000 oh
was it 12 600 down to 63 which is good
well actually it's great
and like I mentioned you can download
all the hashes for offline use and
clouds were even cached the big single
fall downloads which were like almost 15
gigabytes they of course are compressed
we're not like giving you a 60 gigabyte
text file so it's the single file
downloads are compressed already
but this this is what they do and like I
said great success
so we had all static data cached for a
long time or until we purchased
not a 100 hit ratio because cloudflare
has other customers than us so they
might they might need some space on
their Edge node so they might like put
some of our stuff off their author cache
to get make room for something else
but
like almost every request was going
through them and not to the origin
so everything is awesome right
uh
is it though
so
in
December 2021 that's when we actually
open sourced the pawn passwords API and
at the same time we got a lot of new
passwords from the FBI and the NCAA like
225 millions of them
I think the I think the number was that
we went up from
like 400 or something million or 500
something million up to like six or
seven hundred
so there was a very sizable increase to
the amount of data that was in the uh
that was in The Blob files
and like getting a lot of new data like
for this kind of service would be a good
thing right
Well turns out there are limits to how
big a single item in the Cache can be
and why do I say a single item
because I mentioned the
big files that you can download like The
like I want to get a zip file of all the
shot one hashes like one big file 15
gigabytes like almost 15 gigabytes that
was before they added 225 million new
passwords in there so
the limit for Pawn password was 15
gigabytes
and how do we know this well we can ask
Troy's wallet and what I mean by asking
for his wallet is
this
this is this is the
expenditure report Troy God that month
see everything is fine up until December
20th
when is Bill skyrocketed like absolutely
skyrocketed 11 448 Australian dollars
which is like I think it's around
the exchange rate at the time I think
it's around like 8 000 US dollars
so we had to take a look at this like
what's going on we gotta investigate
so we started looking at the clock for
dashboards
and this is that uh
that
that day so I'm gonna point a few things
out
this was in 24 hours all of a sudden the
origin had served three terabytes of
data
and it was due to cash missions
now you can see like I don't can't
really tell how clear it is like the
little green bar there is the text files
they were all being cached so those
weren't the problem but what it says bin
there's the binary files the big sipped
text files
they were hardly ever being cashed
so
there was a something that wasn't
oversight but when you have a service
with this amount of traffic little
oversight can result in a pretty massive
build
we solved the issue by removing the file
download syncfall downloads
put in uh like Azure expenditure like
monitors and alerting so we now get
alerts if the expenditure starts starts
Rising too quickly
and we to bring back the syncophile
downloads We decided to create a
downloader we also thought use this
opportunity because
as we've added the API for like the FBI
in others to put stuff in there we
realized that the data would be changing
a lot more often than it did
so we decided okay we'll just create a
downloader we'll open source it and I
can just download all the files because
you have a limited range of
like file names that you can get so it's
pretty easy to just go through them it's
pretty much just a for Loop
everything was good for a while
but then we added the ntlm hashes that
was February this year
so adding the ntlm hashes
was like wasn't hard like we already had
all the data so we decided okay we'll
just like
this was a this was like a big feature
request so we decided okay we'll just
put all the antenna hashes into like new
text files put that up there and update
the Azure function
and we thought well everything's good
until Troy slides into my DMs uh saying
like wondering why the egress data is
still quite High
and we it took a while to figure this
out but in the end it just pretty much
just came down to numbers
um
what happened when we actually
introduced the ntlm hashes was that we
added 1 million files again so we went
from one million files to two million
files
so
that the amount of files that were being
increased
basically caused cloudflare to start
like we were taking up instead of taking
like a million slots for the cash and if
we started taking 2 million
and like I said they have other
customers so they might have to put
things off the cache
so items were getting like pulled it off
their Edge cache more frequently
unfortunately
that means that
the Xiao one hashes which were primarily
once being fetched because this was a
new feature it meant that they started
to get get booting up more often
and like we saw earlier when like the
cash hit rate drops the bills go up
so we started talking to Cluster okay
how can we get the cash hit rate back up
and cloud4 hash
a thing called Cloud for cash Reserve
now cash Reserve is I think it's still
in beta but what it is is a cash for the
cash
so we spent less cash
but how does it work
it's not it's not very complex it's
between the origin and the edge nodes
and it's just magic
but it's not really magic it's built on
what they call R2
which is
a bit of a naming like they're making a
little bit of fun with Amazon there
because they have S3 does the same thing
it's just three compatible so they call
it R2 it's basically just uh another
like
storage bucket
so what they actually do is they sit
between the edge nodes and the origin
and as the like requested the origin
they start saving them
to uh to their cash Reserve
but to do this they have some
requirements uh because these are things
that are being stored like this is this
is not just
this is no longer just living in the
attitude this is living in a bucket
somewhere so they have some requirements
like of course the data needs to be
cachable which it is we're just like
serving a bunch of text files
she had a time to live at least 10 hours
like check
um and then needs to return a constant
length header like we already know how
big the files are so not a problem
where is it
we thought this wasn't a problem because
like we tested this of course locally
and
you always got a Content length header
but when we pushed it to Azure we
stopped getting the conflict header
and we were trying to figure out
what's going on
now Azure which in this case like has is
serving this data they saw that the
requests were coming in for text files
and tax files are not jpegs or zip files
so
they're usually on compressed data so
IIs in Azure thought hey I'm just going
to be I'm just going to be helpful this
is static data I'm just gonna
dynamically compress it on the way out
as I'm responding
so trying to be helpful I guess
but the way Dynamic compression works is
it gets the actual data and it as it's
streaming it out it just compresses it
that is if the client actually can
handle it
but I'm wondering if any of you can spot
the problem here
so
like I said it's dynamically compressing
things so it doesn't know how big the
response is going to be until it's
finished responding
so this is bringing any bells
what's the first thing that gets as like
the first part of the response from an
HTTP server
it's the headers right
headers include content length which
should tell you how big the response is
going to be but as Azure is responding
it doesn't know how big the response is
going to be because it's not done
compressing it it doesn't compress it
all in memory because if you would be
serving a 15 gigabyte file like you'd be
taking up all the memory on the server
so as the response letters are sent
before the actual response is sent
well obviously
uh it removes the content length header
now this took a while to figure out but
we thought all right
they are compressing the data like
because they they're trying to be
helpful and make sense for like most use
cases
but we'll just go ahead and disable the
compression and actually Dynamic
compression
but we can't
and I can tell you I really really tried
I think I tried every possible setting I
could find even some settings I probably
shouldn't have found
um
try to mess with I tried to mess with
like configuration files and everything
else to turn this off until I finally
just basically got a response saying
nope sorry you can't
and upon receiving the response this was
sort of my reaction
I was not happy
because
this was a requirement for us to be able
to put the cash Reserve in there and
while we couldn't fix this like the
bills are just going up
so I started thinking a lot about it but
I actually did find the fix in the end
though so this is me hitting the
development
like Azure function directly not going
through cloudflare
as you can see I'm like the content
encoding VR that means broadly that
means it's compressed and I'm getting a
Content length header back
now
this was not this is not the cleanest
solution
but I figured hey like
if I just compress the response before
is gets it there's no reason for is to
compress it
so in the Azure function because I can
assume or like I can assume I know that
the files are not that big I can allow
myself the luxury of just reading them
all into memory compressing them there
and then just handing is back the
compressed response
so that's pretty much what I'm doing I'm
just taking over the responsibility of
doing a compression
depending on if the client supports
compression or not
so
one two requirements so now we fulfill
all the requirements and upon seeing
this work I was quite happy
uh
so this is the current situation
with the functions this is a single day
of requests
going into going into cloudflare for the
for the hash ranges
as you can see like we get
167.31 million requests and 167.31
million requests are served by
cloudflare 184 went to the origin
which if you put this into numbers it's
a
99.9999 hit ratio
which is literally one in a million so
like you can actually see when you're
doing a quest to cloudflare
you can see the response headers if it
was a cache hit or not so if you ever
look at the cash headers uh coming from
the phone password API and you see a
cache miss you can be pretty happy
because you're at literally one in a
million uh right there
so this was this was pretty successful
and this is actually something that we
did just like three months ago
so okay
we thought okay let's wrap things up
without the cloud for caching uh the
Azure request fees and read operations
like I said would exceed 12 000 US
dollars per month and that is not really
sustainable if you're trying to run a
free service uh especially if it's just
like
one person paying for all this
the Azure Network egress fees are free
because they say like first 100
gigabytes are free and we like since we
put in Cloud for cash Reserve we never
exceed that so we're not paying any ego
fees anymore at least from azure
storage Club read operations are free as
well because they give you 10 000 read
operations per month and we never
actually hit those unless we actually
purchase the cash which is rare
so the entire Azure storage build right
now is just like 1.25 US dollars for the
60 gigabytes we store in the blob
storage
cluster does not build egress fees and
this is what actually makes this
possible
but for cash Reserve they actually do
bill you for the amount of data stored
and how many operations they have to
read from the storage similar to the
Azure blob storage they have to store a
lot of data and it's not free
so they bill you for reads right
and usually rights aren't that many like
we only write to the cash Reserve like I
said when we press the cache
but otherwise we're just reading from it
and usually the edge nodes are taking
like a bunch of the hits
so that's not big either
so I think the total amounts to like
16.5 US dollars per month like I said
earlier before we actually hit cash
reserve and before we actually started
getting all the caches evicted
because it would be around 67 per month
but like after ending the ntlm hashes
that would have been rising pretty
quickly
so 16.5 US dollars per month instead of
12 000 is pretty much a 99 saving
so recapping all of this like sort of
what what we've learned from all this is
well the obvious the obvious learning
from this is Cash static data there's no
reason for you to spend CPU Cycles or
memory whatever on constantly serving
data that's never going to change like
you can you can just pull cache it
and return it like that directly
if you have
static data without like long lifetimes
for example if you're serving
let's say zip files that rarely change
or you're serving images that really
change or like you rarely update a CSS
or whatever
should think about serving it over a CDN
because that will actually bring that
data a lot closer to the users so it'll
be a lot faster to fetch it and it's
never going to hit your servers at least
rarely
only the scheme and the host in the URL
are case insensitive it's what I was
explaining with the URL normalization
so these two URLs are not the same and
not not according to web servers a lot
of web servers they'll do automatically
like if they would get one of these and
they were like working against the case
into the file system and not finding
they would just try okay can I find
another file that fits
but you should never assume that the
URLs are or whatever serving the URLs is
is case insensitive
you need to make sure that you can
easily Purge or invalidate the cache
when you have like either on your site
or the CDN to include like cloudflare
azure
like Azure TDN Amazon cloudfront they
all have apis that do this for you or
dashboards where you can like click a
button and do this to make it easier
but a good thing to also think about is
for example in the case of CSS or
JavaScript it would be good for you to
just not have like my site.js and when
it changes then users are not going to
get the new version because all of them
have cached it it'd be good for example
to append something to the file name
like the hash level file or something
else because then if the file changes
you'll be getting a different file name
so that's uh that's a good thing to do
as well
be aware of caching limits in our case
the the 15 gigabyte one was like
it was not really well documented it's
not sort of an extreme case but usually
all the CDN or Cache providers will
actually tell you like you need to do
this and this and this for everything to
work
one of them is for example the headers
make sure that they comply with whatever
the CDN requirements you have because
otherwise you're putting a CD in front
it's not going to do anything because
you're not telling it the correct things
to do
and that sort of
that sort of brings it down to the
the gist of it of of actually how this
is done I mean like none of this is
really complex for especially for static
data but as soon as you start getting
Dynamic data there are all the things
you have to think about
now
I decided to uh leave a lot of room for
questions if you have any
um
this is
it's not a topic that like a lot of
people think about but probably should
if you're serving any kind of data so
if you have any feel free to bring them
on
so the question is are we afraid that
cloudflare might change this pricing
policy uh no not at the moment at least
they
they like make themselves out to be like
uh they make themselves out to be fast
and have these pricing policies and
usually for these big companies when
they're changing their pricing policies
they usually get a very big heads up
or like at least some some uh a very
good time in advance for you to actually
respond to it so it's not really
something we're worried about at the
moment at least
anyone else
yep
so the question is like because we're
storing files based on the first five
digits of the hash
like would it make a difference if we
put it down to six uh
the difference would be that well the
obvious difference would be we would go
from one million files to 60 million
files
so then this is sort of a convenience
thing but like the more digits we would
actually put in the hash
the more chances are of someone actually
identifying what passwords you're
looking up because we'd be giving like
uh would be gaming servers for everyone
in the middle of proxy servers like more
information even if it's just six digits
but you've you've cut the you've cut the
like possibilities of the passwords down
a lot there will be it would be smaller
files would be returning but we found
that five digits uh pretty much The
Sweet Spot there
someone else
all right
so thank you very much then
you can find my blog there if you want
find me on Twitter send me an email if
you have more questions
I have a bunch of album stickers here in
front which you can feel free to grab if
you want
um don't forget the feedback on your way
out
and enjoy the rest of NDC thank you very
much
[Applause]